Just last year, fossils of our species were dated to
300,000 years ago, much earlier
than anyone had suspected.
But archaeologist have struggled to find many
securely dated fossils and stone tools
from this critical time.
Now a team of researchers have uncovered
a panoply of evidence of early human behavior dating
back 320 thousand years ago to the Middle Stone Age.
--from the use of sophisticated tools,
to social networks, and pigments.
This toolkit emerged shortly after our ancestor’s brains
underwent a big surge in size 400 hundred thousand
years ago and just before fossils that may be very
early members of our species appeared.
The research is part of a multi-decade project at sites
in the Olorgesailie Basin of Southern Kenya.
There, the team excavated some small carefully shaped
tools made of obsidian,
which is valued for its sharpness.
The tools were made by striking small blades and
points off an asymmetrical core
into a desired shape and thickness.
This suggests complex planning, more than
the earlier relatively clunky, large stone tools such as
the hand ax or scraper.
The opposite ends of the points were sometimes
modified to allow them to be attached to shafts.
This projectile technology is an important step
in the development of hunting.
For fast and dangerous prey, these tools could be
flung at a distance with reduced danger to the hunter.
The team analyzed the stone artifacts and compared
them to the locations of obsidian sources in Kenya.
They found that the rocks must have been
transported from as far 90 kilometers away--
farther than individuals were likely to walk.
This suggests that the rock for making stone tools
and other objects may have been passed
hand to hand in a network of ancient humans.
Such networks would have required considerable
social and cognitive complexity.
This is the earliest evidence of
human social networks to date.
Just as remarkable was the discovery of rocks
used for coloring.
One site had rocks streaked with black manganese
and other sites revealed processed red ochre.
These pigments may have been used to draw on
people's bodies as a form of symbolic identity.
If you have a red streak on your forehead,
it signals to others, possibly hostile strangers
that you're the person they met with before--
and that you're trustworthy.
So, why and how did these shifts in behavior happen
with Middle Stone Age hominids?
Researchers examined a plethora of evidence
from the basin sediment and found that the time
in which these individuals emerged was one of severe
resource instability and episodes of scarcity.
These ancient humans may have expanded
their social networks and hunting skills as a means
to survive such unpredictable, changing conditions.
Researchers have yet to uncover hominin fossils
from the Middle Stone Age at Olorgesailie.
But the tools tell us much about their makers.
These new discoveries provide strong support
that some aspects of modern behavior have
deep roots and emerged early in Africa;
then evolved gradually over time.